My wife grew up in Santa Rosa, California,
and her best friend
was a woman named Joy Durand
who lived on the northeast
outskirts of town.
At midnight on the evening
of October 8, 2017,
Joy's telephone rang.
The voice said simply,
"You must evacuate now.
You don't have time to pack.
Fire is coming."
Joy gathered her parents
and her six-year-old son,
and they hurried outside.
The wildfire, which at that point
was just over the ridge from Joy's house,
sounded like a jet engine
going at full throttle.
The family got in their car, drove away,
and within minutes,
their home had burned to the ground,
incinerated by the blowtorch flames
of the Tubbs Fire.
All night long, my wife got texts
and messages from friends and family,
and while we didn’t know
the whole situation,
it was clear that a disaster
was unfolding in her hometown.
No one thought that fire could penetrate
so deeply into the city.
But on that evening,
22 people lost their lives
and over five thousand homes
and structures were destroyed.
Wildfire is a large and growing challenge
to the West and to the world.
What happened in Santa Rosa
is becoming all too common.
Paradise in 2018, Australia in 2020,
Europe in 2022.
And fire experts say
that we should get ready
for more Santa Rosas
because it's likely to get worse
before it gets better.
Now beyond the major costs
in lives and property and the economy,
there's also a big
carbon impact to wildfire.
In fact, the additional carbon
from California's 2020 wildfires
was greater than the carbon
that Californians had worked
so hard to save
over the previous two decades.
The largest fires are called megafires.
These are the ones
that burn over 100,000 acres
with the intensity that can threaten
aquifers and biodiversity,
and even cause forest conversion,
in which trees are so damaged
that they just don't grow back.
These fires are getting worse as well.
In fact, eight of the ten
largest megafires in California history
have happened
over just the last five years.
Many people feel overwhelmed
by this situation.
I know I did.
So two years ago,
working with great people,
I closed a chapter
of my life in aerospace
and I started a new journey
to see if I could understand
the wildfire crisis better
and what could be done about it.
I started working with leaders
from firefighting and philanthropy,
entrepreneurship,
science, tribal communities,
and together we cofounded an organization
called Megafire Action,
whose sole purpose
is to solve the megafire crisis.
And I've come to believe
that if we take a holistic approach,
we have an opportunity
to establish a new relationship with fire,
to work safely with fire
and potentially to solve
this wicked problem.
The path forward has three solutions.
The first is fire-adapted communities,
the second is resilient landscapes
and the third is
innovative fire management.
So for the first,
fire-adapted communities,
what we need to do is to clear the brush
and the vegetation from homes,
from the immediate proximity of homes.
Next, we need to
use fire-resistant materials
in the homes and the roofs.
And then the third thing
is to, where possible,
protect against embers, flying embers,
by protecting the home from openings
like your air vents and your chimneys.
Now communities have
a strong shared interest
to perform this work along
the exterior boundary of the community
because it reduces the chance
that fire will penetrate
deeply into the city,
as it did in Santa Rosa.
The second solution
is resilient landscapes.
And if you take one lesson
from this talk, it's this.
In order to solve the megafire crisis,
we need to bring our western landscapes
back into a healthy balance
by reducing the overgrown brush and trees
in the wildlands and the forest.
Here we're finally starting
to take to heart the wisdom
of the Indigenous peoples of the Americas
who knew that fire was
a natural part of the landscape
and who introduced low-intensity fire,
good fire, on a regular basis,
at the right times.
When this is done well,
as around the communities
of South Lake Tahoe,
then it can actually divert a megafire
as bad as the one
that they experienced in 2021.
It can also potentially prevent
a megafire from occurring,
which is what some people think
happened in Napa of last year.
But the scale of this challenge is huge.
There are hundreds of millions of acres
of wildland in the American forests.
The Forest Service
hopes to reduce the risk
on 50 million high-priority acres
over the next ten years.
But the challenge is that they're only
accomplishing a few million acres a year.
And so we're not at the pace or scale
that we need to do
to address this challenge.
So what do we need to do?
Well, the first thing that we need to do
is to essentially hire,
train and retain many more workers
who will be doing the hard work
of defusing the time bombs
inside our western forests.
We need to pay them well.
We need to support them
with full-time work
and we need to protect them
from liability where necessary.
The next thing we need to do
is to empower them with innovation.
And right now there are
an incredible number of great companies
and organizations that are working
to bring this innovation to reality.
Just one of these companies
is called BurnBot,
and what they're hoping to do
is to make controlled burns
safer and faster.
They're going to establish
a burned perimeter around an area
with the remotely piloted rover
and then they can bring a drone
into the middle of it,
drop some fire into it
and burn that interior area safely.
It's a brilliant but a simple idea.
And I think we're going to need
a lot more of this kind of innovation
if we're going to scale up
to the to the size of the problem
that we have before us.
Now the first two solutions
that I've talked to you about
are pretty well agreed.
The third one, innovative fire management,
is somewhat more controversial,
but I think it offers huge potential
to address and solve the wildfire problem.
What we need is innovation and technology
that can rapidly detect and assess fire
and then quickly put it out
when it gets bad.
And here, speed is paramount,
because when you're
in the worst kind of fire days --
these are the hottest,
driest and windiest fire days --
if you can't bring fire management
resources to a fire very quickly,
then it is likely that you
won't be able to contain that fire.
Here we need to look at the example
of the Quick Reaction Force
of Southern California,
which is really designed
in some ways for these toughest days.
The QRF is a public-private partnership,
which now has three Chinook helicopters.
These are the big ones
with the two rotors on the top.
And each of them can drop
up to 3000 gallons of water on a fire,
day or night,
and they can do it very precisely.
They can also refill
up to six times an hour
so they can bring
a lot of mass to the problem.
Over the course of two years
of demonstrations,
the QRF has demonstrated
that this model has great potential,
that, in fact, if you can bring
a lot of fire management resource
to a fire very quickly,
you can get on top of fires
before they get big and unmanageable.
And this opens up
an exciting potential future.
Imagine this model
with a series of larger drone vehicles
distributed across the landscape
in higher-fire-risk areas.
Imagine these vehicles
positioned periodically
along utility lines
or in areas of higher fire-risk
deep in the forest.
Such a distributed network,
if connected to the right sensor system,
could offer a future
in which we are able
to really put out fires
on the worst fire days,
and even in remote communities.
Companies like Rain and Joby Aviation
are working on this vision today.
The sensor system
will also be very important
for the resolution of this problem.
The system -- which will entail
both ground-based,
aerial and space-based platforms --
won't be important just because
we're going to be able to see
and detect fire where and when it pops up,
but also because it'll enable us
to differentiate
between good and bad fire,
low-intensity fire
and high-intensity fire,
which is very important because we need
more lower-intensity fire on the landscape
to rejuvenate our forests,
just as much as we need to know
where and when fire risk
is becoming higher intensity.
Fire is a prism through which
we can see the future
of humanity's relationship
with natural systems.
Working together
and supported by technology,
we can build a world in which communities
are resilient to wildfire
and in which forests
are brought back into a healthy balance.
Ultimately, we can build a future,
in which we don't just manage fire
to protect human life and property,
but also to protect the biosphere
for global carbon emissions
and for biodiversity.
Ultimately, we need to become
the crew of Spaceship Earth.
So let's get to work.
Let's learn from fire
and let's build a resilient,
sustainable future.
Thank you.
(Applause)